when longtime superman aficionados
learned that cw
superman and lois would be taking its
namesake couple back to smallville they
knew they could expect two things
earthtone barns with terrible alien
secrets hidden underneath them and lana
lang
for over half a century lana lang has
held a special place in superman fans
hearts as his other notable romantic
interest
generally speaking she's clark's anchor
to his early life reminding him of the
simpler days back on the farm
she's been played by a small pantheon of
performers bunny henning in the
short-lived 1961
superboy series annette o'toole in
superman 3 and kristen kruek in the
increasingly weird and retrospect
smallville years
superman and lois brings a new lana to
the table this time living the american
dream
married to the local fire chief with a
couple of kids and a sleeping pill
problem here the troubled denizen of the
sunflower states is played by emanuel
shriki
you may recognize her the canadian
actress has been a near-constant
presence in television and movies for
more than 25 years
in 1972 kung fu told the story of kwai
chang kang a disgraced shallow and monk
traveling the us in the late 19th
century
writing wrongs and kicking the problems
of the less fortunate the series became
a cult classic in 1993 saw the release
of a follow-up series kung fu the legend
continues
here original series star david
carradine played the grandson of kwai
chang kang
helpfully also named kwai chang kang and
even more helpfully abandoning the
cowboy set pieces of the old days and
pharaoh the cost-friendly streets of
toronto
the list of guest performers who wanted
in on the action is intimidating
victor garber george lazenby george
takei and even a bright-eyed young ryan
gosling made appearances on the series
and so did emmanuel shariki in her very
first credited on-screen performance
she made her television debut in the
1995 episode the return of sing ling
playing a character named bumper
emanuel shariki's next notable
appearance was in 2003's wrong turn
she played carly one of a small
entourage of youths whose weekends get
ruined when their car gets a flat tire
because some backwoods cannibals put
barbed wire in the road that experience
surely prepared her for a next notable
role in hbo's entourage
for eight seasons and a movie entourage
kept its viewers wrapped attention
conveying the adventures of movie star
vincent chase and his crew of hangers on
it was also one of emmanuel shiriki's
steadier gigs following her debut in the
season 2 episode the bop mitzvah
don't remember her you don't remember me
sloane
sloan mcewick right that's right good
memory she played sloane mcewick
a sometimes girlfriend of one eric e
murphy the two would be on again off
again for the majority of the series
finally getting together on a permanent
basis during the show's final season
shariki even appeared in the 2015
entourage movie giving birth to the
couple's baby girl
before making the trip to smallville
kansas emmanuel sriki headed north of
the border to her native canada for a
role in super troopers 2 the sequel to
the 2001 stoner classic which helped put
members of the broken lizard comedy
troop on the map
in the follow-up captain john o'hagan
gets the gang of spurbery's finest back
together for a special mission
it seems that a recently discovered
border discrepancy means the southern
part of ontario canada
is actually supposed to be the northern
part of vermont your favorite former
members of the vermont highway patrol
are tasked with establishing a local
police department and liaising with her
counterparts on the royal canadian
mounted police
chiriki gets in on the action as
genevieve a french-canadian cultural
attache assigned to help facilitate the
transfer of land
at least that's her cover story she's
also an undercover officer for ontario
provincial police
actually assigned to help bring down the
drug smuggling operation that provides
the film's dramatic backbone
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book heroes and
villains are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one